what was your all-time favorite Weasley
twin shenanigan over the course of all
the movies
the joke shop in the sixth movie that
was my favorite uh because the set was
amazing and it was all about us it was
every actor wants her least favorite
scene quidditch in the third movie
because it was it was blues or green
screen and they sting can take a while
anyway because they need to match up
with all the other uh effects that were
going on but it was set in the rain so
we were soaking wet we had a giant like
fan blowing at you what made you look
like you're flying so that was cold
um yeah that's I feel get shuddered when
I think about it both physically and
methodox